so meanwhile we have our daughtering old
fool of a president who has somehow
pulled defeat from the draws of victory
with the economy pulled defeat from the
jobs of victor the jaws of victory uh
with regard to kovid and now he's
pulling defeat from the draws of victory
with regard to foreign policies he
already did this in afghanistan he
literally just surrendered afghanistan
to a bunch of eighth century tribal
barbarians who stuff women into bags and
then stuff them into the basement and
starve children and marry off those
children for an actual fee
you just gave up a country to those
people and now he is facing down other
crises from russia from china
from iran it's hilarious he keeps going
to iran and he's like can we can we make
a deal i don't know a nuclear broker
blue
and ron's like um no
because we don't want to am i supposed
to please everything
and then iran's like no we don't want to
and israel is like what if we just blow
up an iranian nuclear reactor how about
that
how about that
joe biden man he's such a joke the the
two big foreign policy crises right now
not iran russia and china
according to the wall street journal
three potential crises are proceeding in
tandem a potential russian invasion of
ukraine continuing chinese pressure on
taiwan and the potential collapse of
iran nuclear talks
any one of these standoffs has the
potential to shake the world order and
produce wider conflict
taken together they signal the us and
its allies are at a dangerous moment
perhaps more dangerous than many
americans realize the challenge for
biden and the democratic leaders he'll
be consulting with this week is to find
a way to show firmness on each front
without provoking a crisis now joe biden
is about to hold a democratic conference
there is one problem which is that the
democracy summit is being attended by a
bunch of places that are not actual
democracies gensake was asked about this
yesterday about the human rights record
of some of the so-called democracies
attending this thing
didn't go great
the democracy summit that will happen
later this week is an opportunity to
bring together
u.s officials civil society leaders and
foreign leaders who represent
a diverse
array of experiences
to talk about strengthening democracy
defending against authoritarianism
fighting corruption and promoting
respect for human rights uh inclusion or
an invitation is not a stamp of approval
on their approach to democracy nor is
exclusion uh a stamp of uh the opposite
of that of disapproval
they're so strong on human rights this
administration man they i i think that
they've got a handle on all of this so
um when it comes to china china is now
building military bases in the pacific
they're they're seeking their first
military base on africa's atlantic coast
according to us intelligence according
to the wall street journal classified
american intelligence reports suggest
that china intends to establish its
first permanent military presence on the
atlantic ocean in the tiny central
african country of equatorial guinea
according to u.s officials the officials
declined to describe details of the
secret intelligence findings but they
said the reports raised the prospect
that chinese warships would be able to
re-arm and refit opposite the east coast
of the united states a threat that is
setting off alarm bells at the white
house and the pentagon
so hemming in china that's going really
well particularly after we surrendered
in afghanistan and made clear that we
are a complete and utter paper tiger
the great power skirmishing over a
country that rarely draws outside
attention reflects the rising tensions
between washington and beijing according
to the wall street journal the two
countries are sparring over the status
of taiwan china's testing of a
hypersonic missile the origins of kova
19 and other issues
worldwide the united states finds itself
maneuvering to try to block china from
projecting military power from new
overseas bases from cambodia to the
united arab emirates
in equatorial guinea the chinese likely
have an eye on bata according to us
official bata already has a
chinese-built deep water commercial port
on the gulf of guinea excellent highways
link the city to gabon and the interior
of central africa
the most significant threat from china
would be a militarily useful naval
facility on the atlantic coast of africa
said general stephen townsend commander
of u.s africa command by militarily
useful i mean something more than a
place they can make port calls and get
gas and groceries i'm talking about a
port where they can re-arm with
munitions and repair naval vessels
so things are are going really well with
the chinese meanwhile gensake and the
bod administration they are taking the
overwhelmingly brutal move of saying
they won't send official representatives
to the beijing olympics i'm sure that xi
jinping is just quaking in his boots i
mean after all of the all the harsh
treatment we gave them for unleashing a
virus on the world that killed upwards
of five million people i'm sure that
he's quaking in his boots that we won't
be sending an undersecretary of state
from tony blinken's
coffee break room over to beijing for
the winter olympics probably xi jinping
is like oh my god that's crazy what are
we going to do now except for everything
we were going to do before here was jen
saki announcing this massive move
the biden administration will not send
any diplomatic or official
representation to the beijing 2022
winter olympics and paralympic games
given the pierre scenes ongoing genocide
and crimes against
humanity and xinjiang and other human
rights abuses the athletes on team usa
have our full support we will be behind
them 100 percent as we cheer them on
from home we will not be contributing to
the fanfare of the games
okay and i'm sure that the china
so basically what we've now achieved by
not sending a diplomat to china is to
piss off the chinese without actually
doing anything which seems to be a great
strategy that that's great meanwhile the
russians are mobilizing almost two
hundred thousand troops along the
ukrainian border
and vladimir putin is making demands
according to the washington post
reporter isabel kursujian and paul sohn
with russian troops massed along the
border with ukraine president vladimir
putin is expected to issue president
biden an ultimatum during a video
meeting on tuesday
guaranteed that nato will never expand
into ukraine or russia might soon launch
an offensive against its neighbor the
kremlin has said it wants written
guarantees from the united states and
allies in nato that the military
alliance will not expand east both in
terms of membership and western forces
the video call comes during an
unprecedented low point in u.s russia
relations especially over ukraine wait i
i was told that hillary clinton was
going to hit the reset button i was told
that that joe biden was a masterful
manipulator of the international scene
by the way anybody who told you that's
an idiot i mean it was barack obama who
famously said don't underestimate joe
biden's ability to f things up
it was robert gates former secretary of
defense under both obama and under bush
who said um yeah this guy has never made
a right decision on foreign policy the
white house has threatened russia with
serious consequences wow like sanctions
ooh
that's obviously those sanctions they've
done wonders for our anti-russian
position those sanctions on particular
figures inside the russian national
system so they just use a bunch of
cutouts to move their money it's
obviously really deterred the russians
putin plans to outline russia's proposal
to joe biden kremlin spokesman dmitry
peskov said monday their talks are
expected to be quite long and
substantive i'm sure that that is going
to be um
uh by quite long and substantive they
mean that joe biden is going to fall
asleep 10 minutes into the conversation
and then vladimir putin is just going to
threaten him for a while and then joe
biden his unconscious face is going to
slam into the hang up button on the
phone that's how that's how world war
iii starts is with the president
slipping into unconsciousness and his
hand hitting the nuclear button
that seems like uh how this is gonna
work out
meanwhile over at the white house uh
they they're trying to struggle for like
what do they do here so a reporter asked
the white house you know joe biden was
vice president when vladimir putin took
over crimea and uh he did a bad job then
so why why are we supposed to believe
he's going to do a good job now
you mentioned that that biden was
obviously deeply involved with the
ukraine in 2014 and i'm wondering if you
could talk about
what his takeaways are from that
experience because a lot of the things
that he's saying this time supporting
nato allies on the eastern flank
sanctions those sound like the same
things that you guys tried to do in 2014
and it didn't stop russia from taking
crimea so what's
why does he think this will be different
well i think first um uh our objective
at this point mara is of course to
prevent them from moving forward
um that didn't answer the question so
the reporter is like yeah last time you
tried this uh putin took crimea he's
like right but but he hasn't taken
ukraine yet and the person that's what
i'm asking you actually
no answer from the administration
according to the washington post biden
plans to make clear to putin what costs
the united states and its allies will
impose on russia if an invasion occurs
but also will offer a diplomatic pathway
that could address russian concerns
about nato activities as well as u.s and
european concerns about russian
activities the official said speaking on
condition of anonymity
still the official suggested a written
guarantee from washington that nato will
not expand to include ukraine as a
non-starter noting the united states
believes every sovereign nation should
have the right to make its own decisions
about its security well putin has to
know that right putin has to know that
the west is not going to give him a
written guarantee that nato will never
include ukraine which means that he's
basically just looking for an excuse
to invade ukraine
now this seems like it's not a big deal
up until the point where putin crosses
that border with a hundred thousand
troops at that point this becomes a very
serious situation indeed
because what exactly is the west
prepared to do
we obviously are not prepared to put a
trigger force in there that would prompt
a wider
fight back against the russians
we've given the russian and the
ukrainian military under under president
trump we'll give them some javelin
missiles but
they they've not been rearmed under
biden to any serious extent
sanctions ain't gonna do it
so if you're vladimir putin probably
what you do is just grab another piece
of ukraine
not the whole thing you walk into kiev
or something
and then you dare the west to do
anything about it and given what we did
over georgia given what we did over
crimea the the answer is probably the
west does nothing over it
and vladimir putin just goes home
notches another win
and the west once again just starts
taking russian oil
there's a famous quote attributed to
stalin
that you uh you basically push where
there's mush
meaning that
wherever the other side is willing to
give that's where you push vladimir
putin has yet to discover the hardcore
of the west and uh it is questionable as
whether there is a hardcore in the west
anymore
when we said that there was a mistake
for the biden administration to randomly
pull out of afghanistan because it
conveyed weakness there are consequences
to that weakness and that is the
exacerbated chances of a great power
conflict for sure
meanwhile cnn's jeff seleni he points
out and he is correct there is no
appetite for us military intervention in
ukraine here's the thing the less
appetite you show for military
intervention the more your enemies are
going to dare you to intervene
this is the way that it works the way
deterrence works is the more
right strength piece through strength
the the reagan-esque slogan was designed
to mean we will show you that we are
willing to go to war so we don't have to
it seems that the new american style is
we will show you that we are never
willing to go to war and then war is
somehow randomly thrust upon us here's
cnn's jeff zeleny pointing out the
obvious here
there is no appetite here for military
intervention
on a briefing earlier with a senior
administration official uh there was uh
several moments of silence when that
question was asked about a military
solution to all of this does the u.s
have the stomach for that so of course
they're not ruling anything out but they
simply do not want to add another thing
which would be uh you know a
significantly uh
dangerous thing to the plate of this by
administration which is already quite
full quite frankly
america's enemies are on the move
they're on the move because they sense
weakness from this administration and
they are right to sense weakness from
this administration this is a weak
administration a deeply weak
administration
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video